mr. Dwayne wave what's up
[Applause]
I'm gonna use my phone and speak I can't
do this uh paper stuff if y'all don't
mind I'm sorry
so when I was asked to uh to come here
today I I merely say yes
I started asking myself what was I gonna
say so I asked my team to send me an
outline of things I could talk about and
after reading what they send me in
editions that I came up with I decided
to read it out loud to my wife smart
right so she looked at me and she said
it's fine
and but if anyone noticed significant
others
you know they tone and you know they
look so I knew it was more to it and
then she said this he asks me a question
she said do you won't fine with like
that like do you want fine what do you
want this speech to mean something so I
thought about it
thought I'll share a little bit of how I
became a part of this MSD family
so I remember I remember having my
business manager reach out to the school
and an accident it was okay if I came on
a first day back
I remember being in the car driving all
the way out to the school and thinking
to myself where am I
I remember pulling up and sent a few
security guys outside
I remember being met by one of the
staffers I remember us walking to the
school and I remember hearing absolutely
nothing
I remember thinking to myself I've never
felt I've never heard this kind of
silence before my life
I started thinking about what I heard in
the news I started thinking about
everything I read on social media and I
immediately started getting butterflies
in my stomach
I remember being so nervous to see you
meet everybody what would I say
I mean I grew up in the city of Chicago
and I've experienced a lot of awful
thing
but I've never experienced anything to
the magnitude that you guys have just
experienced
so I remember walking in and meeting
this to happen and actually being
surprised that everyone was excited to
see me
then I remember hearing someone say you
know go to the cafeteria and that's why
I'll be able to say a few words to the
students
I remember thinking again I have no idea
what I'm gonna say
and what started going through my mind
was how do I dare come in here and act
like I know it was how do I dare come
here and act like I know what you guys
have been going through
how narcissistic of me to think I could
come here and make a difference because
I'm good at my sport
I remember walking slowly to the
cafeteria as I was walking in students
start to see me started seeing smiles
people run in pulling out their phones
showing their followers on Instagram and
snapchat and some other cool app that
I'm just not cool enough to know
anything about and I remember thinking
wow
it was packed I didn't expect that
actually I actually really didn't know
what to expect
but I remember the smiles the looks of
joy
I remember feeling this insane energy so
I grabbed the mic and started speaking
from the heart and in that moment I
realized something
I realized that we have so much more in
common than I even knew I realized that
at that moment we all had a
responsibility a responsibility to be
seen to be heard to stand up and stand
tall for the ones that no longer had a
voice
thank you
what you do with each of these moments
will determine how much greater this new
chapter would be I want you to take
pride in what you already accomplished
what hasn't been broke what has been
brought to you what does being brought
you what has brought you to these seats
today have joy when you reflect on all
the lessons you've learned along the way
don't sit in your fear but stand firm in
your belief in yourself
so in closing
I had this mantra that I came up with no
actually I didn't come up with it
actually I did not just like I had this
mantra it's my fate one of my favorite
movies is Red Tails and in 2013 when the
Miami he was he was going to hit it to
our second championship in a row we hit
a little little spot and I felt like we
needed something to bring us together
and I and I decided to to talk into to
bring his cheer to the team and this is
the mantra that we came up with mr.
Machar we use every game before we
stepped out on the court so I just asked
you guys to join me in this chair is
that okay all right but I'm gonna need
y'all help all right so I know you guys
are very smart
I heard someone had a 5-point 3,000 GPA
so I know y'all will get this so
all right we gonna we're gonna say it
once today we gonna say it together out
there alright so I'm gonna say nothing's
difficult you guys are gonna say
everything's a challenge let's try it
nothing's difficult okay we got that all
right
throughout versity you guys say to the
stars to iversity the next three lines
is me imma say to the last man to the
last minute to the last second and then
I'm gonna say we fight y'all gonna say
we fight alright i'ma say it three times
and y'all gonna say it back three times
okay so I'm gonna say we fight y'all
gonna say i'ma say we fight y'all gonna
say I'm gonna say we fight y'all gonna
say I hope y'all got there we gonna say
this together then we're gonna say it
like a team y'all ready y'all ready all
right
nothing's difficult to iversity
to the last man to the last minute to
the last second we fight we fight we
fight let's go thank you guys and miss D
strong
[Applause]